should systems like gpt4 be open sourced
in the whole arm part can you make the
can you see the case for either
I think the answer right now is no
I think the answer early on was yes
so we could bring in uh all the
wonderful great thought process of
everybody on this but asking should we
open source gpt4 now is just the same as
if you say well is it good should we
open source
um
you know how to build really small
nuclear weapons should we open source
how to make bio weapons should you open
source how to make um
a new virus that kills 90 of everybody
who gets it of course we shouldn't
so it's already that powerful
it's already that powerful that we have
to respect the power of the systems
we've built
the knowledge that you get
um
from open sourcing everything we do now
might very well be powerful enough that
people looking at that
can use it to build the things that are
really threatening again let's get it
remember open AI is
gpt4 is a baby AI baby sort of baby
Proto almost a little bit AGI according
to what Microsoft's recent paper said
right
it's not that they were scared of what
we're scared about is people taking that
who are
who might be a lot less responsible than
the company that made it right and uh
just going to town with it that's why
we want to
it's it's an information Hazard there
are many things which um you know are
not open sourced right now and Society
for very good reason
like how how do you make
certain kind of very powerful toxins out
of stuff you can buy at Home Depot you
know you know you don't open source
those things for a reason
and uh this is really no different
so uh what I'm saying that I have to say
it's a little it feels in a bit weird
but in a way a bit weird to say it
because MIT is like the Cradle of the
open source movement and I love open
source in general power to the people
let's say um
but um there's always gonna be some
stuff that you don't open source and you
know it's just like you don't open
source so we have a three-month-old baby
right when he gets a little bit older
we're not going to open source to him
all the most dangerous things he can do
in the house yeah
foreign
but it does it's a weird feeling because
this is one of the first moments in
history where so there's a strong case
to be made not to open source software
this is when the software has become
yeah too dangerous yeah but it's not the
first time that we didn't want to open
source a technology technology yeah
is there something to be said about how
to get the release of such systems right
like gpt4 and gpt5
so open AI went through a pretty
rigorous effort for several months you
could say it could be longer but
nevertheless it's longer than you would
have expected of trying to test the
system to see like what are the ways
goes wrong to make it very difficult for
people
somewhat difficult for people to ask
things how do I make a bomb for one
dollar
or how do I say I hate a certain group
on Twitter in a way that doesn't get me
blocked from Twitter banned from Twitter
those kinds of questions so you
basically use the system to do harm yeah
uh is there something you could say
about ideas you have it's just on
looking having thought about this
problem of AI safety how to release a
system how to test the systems when you
have them inside the company
yeah so
a lot of people say that the two biggest
risks from large language models are
it's spreading disinformation
harmful information the various types
and second being used for offensive uh
cyber weapon
so I I think those are not the two
greatest threats they're very serious
threats and it's wonderful that people
are trying to mitigate them
as a much bigger elephant in the room is
how is this it's going to disrupt our
economy in a huge way obviously and
maybe take away a lot of the most
meaningful jobs
and an even bigger one is the one we've
spent so much time talking about here
that that
this
becomes the Bootloader for the more
powerful AI write code connected to the
internet manipulate humans yeah and
before we know it we have something else
which is not at all a large language
model it looks nothing like it but which
is way more intelligent and capable and
has goals
and that's the that's the elephant in
the room and and uh obviously no matter
how hard any of these companies have
tried
um they that's not something that's easy
for them to verify with large language
models and the only way to be
really lower that risk a lot would be to
not let for example try not to never let
it read any code not train on that and
not put it into an API
and um
not
not give it access to so much
information about how to manipulate
humans
so but that doesn't mean you still can't
make a lot
a ton of money on them you know uh we're
gonna
just just watch now this coming year
right Microsoft is rolling out the new
uh office suite where you go into
Microsoft Word and give it a prompt and
it writes the whole text for you and
then you edit it and then you're like oh
give me a PowerPoint version of this and
it makes it and now take the spreadsheet
and blah blah and you know all of those
things I think are you can debate the
economic impact of it and whether
Society is prepared to deal with this
disruption but those are not the things
which
that's not the elephant of the room that
keeps me awake at night for wiping out
Humanity
and
I think that's the biggest
misunderstanding we have a lot of people
think that we're scared or like the
automatic spreadsheets that's not the
case that's not what Eliana was freaked
out about either